das ist natürlich im gegensatz zu euren
lichten intellektuellen einwürfen ein
bisschen banal aber ich komme natürlich
aus dem fernsehgeschäft und ich habe
heute gelesen in der bild zeitung das
wird grauen eine serie wir alle gesehen
haben elf emmys abgeräumt hat und ich
selber habe letzte woche einem gewinner
des des fernsehpreises diesen
überreichen dürfen und habe dann wieder
gegrübelt was ist da anders also es
beginnt schon mal damit der fernsehpreis
der wurde er zwei jahre lang entfernt
sind überhaupt nicht übertragen jetzt
hat sich rtl der sache mit angenommen
ich habe den preis für mein lebenswerk
habe ich mit dhl bekommen er wurde mir
der post zugeschickt wenn das ding aber
und jetzt wurde er gesendet wenn man das
9 prozent marktanteil also
offensichtlich haben die menschen wenig
interesse an dem was da passiert und ich
muss auch zugeben
von den gewinnern kannte ich die
allerwenigsten also ich habe den preis
an einen großartigen schauspieler sascha
alexander gesagt überreicht dem nichts
und niemand leben vorher gesehen hatte
aber ich habe mir jetzt im nachhinein
die serie angeguckt das sind die toten
von mano die wurden für die ard gedreht
und hat eine ausgezeichnete südtiroler
serie gesehen mit tobias moretti über
die mafia was ist der unterschied warum
funktionieren amerikanische serien so
viel besser als unsere weil
offensichtlich und das ist mein naiver
meine e-mails forschungsergebnis dass
die deutschen inszenieren fürs publikum
hoffentlich b aber auch für die
preiswürdigkeit also wenn die
kommissarin bei der toten von nano ins
wasser sinkt dann weißt du da sind drei
taucher mitgeschwommen und eine
maskenbildnerin und dann wird eben im
wurf der haare und dann schwimmt sie von
oben dann ist die kamera mit peer drohte
doch mal von der seite und ich denke nur
stimmlich es gibt es geht bringt uns
weiter und bei diesem neuen krimi da
waren dann auch depressive dialoge
männer niedergedrückt von ihren von
ihrem schlechten gewissen philosophieren
fünf minuten wohl sagen kann jetzt wann
kommt der nächste tote also es ist wenn
man krimis schon macht und wenn man
erfolg haben will und das wissen die
amis das wissen die bei netflix und
sonst auch immer warum machen wie immer
noch so mühsames fernsehen gefördert von
den hintersten im abspann
also ich begreife unsere wirkt unsere
fernseh und film wirklichkeit nicht mehr
und die preiswürdigkeit
scheint offensichtlich nicht das zu sein
was man sich erwartet weil wir uns es
interessiert keine sau mehr
ich glaube auch dass die motivation den
film zu machen ja das entscheidende sven
sein künstlerisches anliegen ist dann
finde ich förderung vollkommen okay wenn
es ein auf unterhaltung ziel der krimi
oder sowas ist dann finde ich schon ein
bisschen schwieriger und zweifelhafter
und wenn bestimmte erzählen formen so zu
sagen du nennst es langweilig und
depressiv und sorgen beladen da ist es
wieder dann im mittelpunkt steht dann
scheint es so zu sein als ob die filme
gar nicht auf unterhaltung zielen
sondern eher auf
belehrung erziehung mitnehmen
so was und das ist schon irgendwie
seltsam
dieses gefühl dass das so ein deutscher
zug zum zum vortrag ich denke der tatort
mit liefers ist ja eigentlich immer
spannend und lustig auch dadurch der
ersten am allermeisten kritisierte woche
meistens ja aber da ist fehlt sagt
kritische komponente völlig aber
vielleicht sind einfach die kriterien
von feldhaus und film fahrer an andere
als die eines massenpublikums ich das
problem geht man tiefer das fängt da das
wir hatten halbstaatliche fernsehsystem
haben öffentlich-rechtliche system was
mit 9 milliarden euro zwangsgebühren
jedes jahr alimentiert wird und das
heißt das ist nicht rückgekoppelt an den
markt nicht zurückgekommen und an die
normalen menschen an die bedürfnisse der
zuschauer sowie die amerikaner wie
selbstverständlich einen film machen
wollen der gesehen wird von vielen
menschen bei uns wird ein film gemacht
der die
menschen der filmförderanstalt überzeugt
das ist einfach ein unterschiedliches
verhalten und deswegen haben wir hier
ein systemisches problem das dann zu
diesen ausformungen führt es ist ich
habe
meinem leben viele tausend filme und
serien eingekauft gerade den usa und da
das ist einfach eine eine andere welt
wie setzen auf den markt die die die
produzieren was
mit dem sie einfach den markt also die
zuschauer überzeugen wollen ja und nicht
irgendwelche kriegen und nicht
irgendwelche wir haben den film fördern
vertreter sondern den markt und und das
einen großen markt haben er hat sich da
auch für eine professionelle struktur
herausgebildet mitautoren ja mit mit
regisseur natürlich auch mit
schauspielern das ist ein ganz anderes
professionalität niveau hier in den usa
und und jetzt kommt's ja kommen der
netflix und amazon prime auch in den
deutschen markt ein und da wird auch
produziert wir haben ja wir haben ja
viele talentierte regisseure und
schauspieler auch glaube ich in
deutschland und in europa aber wir haben
zu wenig mut
auf die bedürfnisse des marktes hin zu
produzieren und diese szene beamten oder
ganz beamten des öffentlich-rechtlichen
systems die sind die killer dieses
dieses mutes es gibt manche redakteure
bei rwe und zu deftig zwischendurch so
einen einteiler mut haben aber in
wirklichkeit ist das alles ein bisschen
gebremst durch die institution ali täter
öffentlich und ich habe auch so ein
bisschen das gefühl das ist so ein
bisschen angst vorm zuschauer weil was
du ansprichst da fand ich auch
bemerkenswert dass also der deutsche
fernsehpreis gar nicht mehr veranstaltet
wurde und gar nicht da kann ich mir im
fernsehen gezeigt wurde weil man zeuge
hatte dass die quote schlecht ist das
heißt auch die branche traut sich selber
gar nicht richtig zu ein event zu
kreieren das so magisch ist und auf
diese tollen sind ja wirklich tolle
tolle tolle leistungen sehen dass man
die strahlen lässt und ich bin
eigentlich froh dass es dieses jahr
wieder stattgefunden ich muss aber auch
sagen dass diejenigen die dann preise
verleihen und die ihnen die rolle kommt
finde ich ihnen ganz nah ja schrecklich
ist übertrieben ganz bezeichnenden satz
gesagt nämlich dass es zwischen dir und
dem preisträger eigentlich gar keine
richtige beziehung gehabt eigentlich war
ja meine vorstellung dass jemand die
laudatio hält der als in gewisser weise
von dem entflammt ist und wenn ich
überlege wo ich die schlechtesten
lobreden gehört aller zeiten dann sind
das meistens preisverleihungen in
deutschland ich erweitere das gehalt wir
sind haben aber ein beispiel in
erinnerung von einer ich bin gar nicht
sicher ob es beim fernsehpreis war oder
bei einer anderen wo irgendwie die
tochter eines sehr berühmten mannes in
deutschland die laudatio auf den vater
halten sollte und sie vom konnte
abgelesen hat mit dem absoluten
gipfelpunkt dass die werke der ist die
steigerung der gipfelpunkt diese
laudatio war dann zum schluss und 1 will
ich dir noch sagen lieber papa ich liebe
dich dann gedacht also
ok und es ist irgendwie der stecker
rausgezogen also die das ist
das verstehe ich nicht springen sie ein
bisschen an geworden preisträger das ist
ja häufig dass bei lassen würde ich ja
bei amerikanischen preis war dann das
sagt doch eine schauspieler war
schauspieler fünf haupt setzen gerade
heraus ja und und auch das geisterreich
ist noch manchmal werden bei uns die
leute nur sagen danke mama danke papa
dann
ja auch für bahnfahrer die haben es doch
genauso ja in rolle ja aber du kannst
doch auch noch ein klein bisschen was
thematisch ist dazu sagen
wie soll man ein gutes machen also was
natürlich ein traum szenario der der
schauspieler den ich da geehrt habe ja
der hat eine tolle dankesrede gehalten
das ist ein grandioser schauspieler und
es war auch ein bisschen peinlich aber
das ist natürlich dann wieder der
redaktion gehen wir also dass das info
bei rtl wir waren die sendung sie es
nicht was passiert also hat man gesagt
dann gehst du mit der barbara ihr wisst
nicht was passiert ihr wisst doch nicht
wer kommt das ist lustig aber letzten
endes ist es dann natürlich es war es
wahnsinn wenn du das machst ist noch in
guten händen also sowas aber das ist ja
manchmal eben nicht in guten händen und
herren kommt
hat mich sehr gefreut
hinterher
sind tolle denn die serie mit
begeisterung gesehen aber immer ja warum
schwimmt die jetzt da
darum die soll geld alle sinken
[Musik]